[Music]
hey hey folks here we are we might be
drunk we're doing it we had a crazy
weekend so we're capping it off with a
little cafe Olay I had I had a little I
had a few too many last night even so
did I what' you drink I just had a
couple of uh mallin with uh with Dan the
bartender at uh the seller oh nice fat
black yeah it's my childhood friend
that's crazy yeah funny how it all comes
back New York we all talking about this
big city that never sleeps I see the
same people all day long every day yeah
this city is uh it's so hard it's such a
great City it's hard not to drink I know
I guess if your life is you drink
or if your life is good you drink but
that's true there's just Bright Lights
it's late and I'm like oh that's a cool
bar I'm going to go in there I know and
the night that crisp night Autumn air is
great in New York that October weather
and all your friends are around you had
a couple good sets give me a highball
yeah it's great SE the groans oh yeah
and we you know we pretty much drink for
free over there so it's hard not to get
a
nice cocktail it's tough yeah guess who
I saw walking down me and the lady took
a stroll cuz the The Village during
Halloween the decorations are out it's
nutty it's great and everyone's a
director now do you see everyone
they take their phone out they're like
let me get this and you're like okay now
you're blocking the walkway exactly some
kid's trying to look at the the scary
ghost and there's a guy felini remember
car fto Rico felini
felini but I see a guy with white hair
and a kid on his shoulders and he's
going look at that Daddy look at that
you know the kids up there guess who it
was who Alec Baldwin oh how about that I
see him in my neighborhood all the time
oh yeah great dad and I said what are
you shooting the no I'm just
kidding shooting joke but uh I went oh
wow and for I just instinctively waved
and and he looked at me like off
and then kept walking yeah it doesn't
sound like a great person well I think
he's out there he need some he needs
some press yeah that's true that's true
this guy's got a podcast where he's GNA
everyone's got a podcast now where
you're like I saw a famous person was he
Nice N yeah but I don't blame him what's
it going to do like hey he didn't even
know who I was so you people like saying
hi to you sometimes and like you always
try to be nice but every once in a while
they catch you at a bad moment yeah I
was having a fight with my mom on the
phone and some guy some guy was like say
I was I was like what the and and
some guys like Sam I was like I was like
and he like okay but that's like that's
pretty good for midf fight that's pretty
good yeah that's tough to do cuz I was
hard take a picture midf fight listen
you inconsiderate hold
on that's all they want is the photo uh
I had I was at the airport and I had a
flight up I had to call Delta which
is always a nightmare and I'm on the
phone with status you go right through I
go right through but you're still like
oh my sky number is this and my flight
time was that I'm doing all that
and the guy was like oh man holy I
listen to you all the time we might be
drunk yeah I'm like shut the up
because I I couldn't hear the lady so he
hated me but now he'll go off and tell
everybody I met him once and he
yelled at me that is it is funny to get
recognized at a bad point I know I know
cuz that's because you are Alec Baldwin
that is your whole life exactly and I
think what Alec Baldwin was saying was
like no photo like don't even try also
he's had he's one of those dudes that
has had too many kids at too late a
point in his life yes that you this is
the point of your life you should be
more restful yes he's got a a
manslaughter charge and more kids you're
not sleeping as well you plus New York
there's noise we're in the same
neighborhood there's a lot of noise
that's true I don't know what's worse
the eight kids of the manslaughter
charge it's it's a tossup plus the
Hilaria Baldwin is no joke that was
rough Hilaria I mean the yogi the Yogi's
already like it can go either way
totally you can be like earthy and kind
of kind or you can just be like all
right enough about granola just
just have another kid already yeah and
then it's also I saw Billy Joel on
Friday and he and he's another one who
has he brought his kids out and they're
way too young for how old he is one of
them was six whoa I think 74 where where
did you see Billy Joel The Garden oh you
saw him performing yeah oh okay yeah
yeah uh girlfriend's birthday she wanted
to see Billy Joel so the garden hooked
it up CU wait when does this come out is
this do I still have time to promote my
date
be wait a minut I never thought about
this so you were playing there so you
get tickets well I try not to abuse it
but they you know they that's good to
know I'm doing the beacon I'm going to
try to get affiliate
baby oh never mind ah well it was a
great night and uh and of course it sold
out yes here here
congratulations you ought to know by now
his voice is still good oh yeah he's
great Rand our boy Brian cman at the
show who told me that he Brian cman if
you don't know creator of billions wrote
rounders amazing
screenwriter uh but he he tells me you
know my first date with my now wife of
30 years was to see Billy Joel and she
stood me up an hour before the show and
now we're going back to see her now what
a comeuppance yeah like I don't care how
long it takes I'm getting you to
that concert but uh no he's amazing dude
oh yeah I saw him live at bonaroo and
you're like bonaroo it's not really his
spot and he owned it he had the best
show he was funny too incredible oh yeah
he had a story where yeah he said he
talked about meeting Keith Richards on
the street and Keith Richards getting
maed by Paparazzi whatever and then as
he's walking by he goes uh he goes Keith
uh Billy Joel and Keith Richards looks
at him like huh huh like that's not what
he thought he'd look like right right a
little self-deprecation from Billy Joel
I liked that I love it not to mention
the you know you can't have a pigot
fence in his neighborhood cuz he will
run it
over he really like to get behind the
wheel he's sober for sure oh okay good
oh dude he's come on but he would let I
mean legendary drunk I'd love to get him
on here damn that would be that would be
an epic download Episode Oh Billy Billy
Joel falls
off we'll bring it a little keyboard
just let him go well the funniest part
is like family singing along to his just
depressing lyrics his lyrics are so
sad yeah but people sing along
like as if you know and John is a real
estate novelist which by the way what
the is a real estate novelist yeah
good point you guys know what that is I
never even thought about that who never
had time for a wife yeah he's sitting
with Davey who's still in the Navy and
he's with her kids who probably will be
for life I'm like that's not that's not
good news not cheerful no what is it
sounds like a woman to me oh she's
always a woman to me yeah it's
controversial now but yeah got to change
that lyric but yeah yeah it's about chz
Bono but yeah hell of an artist and
still kicking and I think he has a
residency like he does 10 a year or
whatever at the G it's amazing yeah he
and he crushed it he it was it was
pretty awesome yeah it's awesome that
every song is a hit yes and then and
he'll like no matter how famous you get
he'll kind there's a little bit where
he's like there's a little song called
Vienna didn't make the chart when it
came out I'm like oh he's still kind of
pissed about it yeah he's bitter good
for him but it's like you're kind of
like holy that wasn't a hit I know
I know they're all great but s b WR it
was like Kendrick Lamar Florence of the
machine mord and Sons it was all these
big hot cool fun artists and then he
came out at the end and blew them all
off the table I parted with Mumford and
Sons one night really they were cool as
yeah they were awesome I remember
one of them was like he's like you know
when you're like week two on the road
and you're on your knees and you're
blowing a line off the seat I was like I
think we're doing the road differently
you guys go hard yeah especially cuz
their music is kind of somber that's how
it always goes though that's true clean
comedian might murder you good point
Peter Paul and Mary look out
yeah Richard Marks I heard he lik the
the heroin and the hookers well Karen
Carpenter that's some dark right
what was her thing she she uh starved
herself to death what isn't that right
Karen Carpenter I know she was anorexic
top that's what it was yeah she died of
that though whoa she went all the way
you see yeah end of the line heart
failure yeah but that's from the from
not eating always impressed when an
American cannot eat good for her it is
everyone else goes the other way it's
not our specialty no no I mean we have
another musician meatloaf yeah named
after food it's a good point it's a good
point yeah and he was a big guy look how
th she it's look at that yikes such a
talent too I know Todd Haynes made a
movie about her and he just used dolls
to do the whole movie oh damn it's weird
as hell it's pretty cool yikes dolls
wait she's not in it obviously no no no
she's dead by the time came out holy
moly dolls musicians I feel like most
artists it's always even the people that
you think are fine look everyone's
up but there's something about
like being a musician I don't know like
it's hard to not be to have some
Darkness there you were talking about
Cobain a minute yeah well also music's
tough because it it you you're hot and
then you go away the whole like disco
guy beg's were the top of the mountain
and then disco is like the the shittiest
thing ever was like not cool and they
just were out of work and also the bgs
are amazing amazing like the
tools that March that what was that
Chicago where that happened where they
were like disco and oh yeah the
Cubs the Cubs what is it field brigley
yeah I love the BS though you
see the documentary it's amazing it's
great cuz they they they fall off
they're the biggest people on Earth and
everybody hates them and they're nerds
and so they start riding for Sher they
start riding for Madonna and then they
they get they get Islands in the Stream
they wrote they wrote it it's a great
tune they wrote a ton of big big hits
that you don't even know that are them
and they're all dead except uh one of
one of them was left is that right yeah
Bo that's a great Doc it's on Max um
yeah a tell else went uh I went to the
decisive game of the WNBA I know some
people going to trash me in the comments
for this but I don't give a I'm
telling the story yeah so the Liberty uh
they're fun games and it's liberty
liberty liberty but uh they're playing
the Las Vegas Aces who the best team
they have injuries they should Liberty
should have won they don't win but we
have the MVP Brianna Stewart she's not
the best player the best players on the
acce is Asia Wilson okay but she got the
MVP for some narrative decisions
whatever tough they lose by one point
we're in the game I see Sam Jay there
which is who you think you're gonna see
at a wnb you hope black lesbian yeah
yeah he would hope you hope and then uh
her who not her who R Ashley Gavin too
yeah white lesbian yeah there you go lot
of lesbians there all right as there
should be that metal detector took a
while to get through catch my drift what
the strapons butt plugs what are we
talking here key chain wallet I don't
know what I was going for there but but
uh no it was a it was a good game it
actually wasn't a good game they got
Banna Stewart played horribly she three
of 18 was a terrible terrible loss they
should have won the game yeah no but as
we're walking out they're having the
celebration cuz the Las Vegas Aces
win and uh you know they they're
blocking the doors I'm like blocking the
doors I don't want to watch the
opposing team celebrate so I'm trying to
leave and they're like blocking us some
pregnant woman bumps me what and she's
with a much older woman and I and I turn
around I say you know we're all trying
to leave yeah and she goes um I'm
pregnant
oh throwing that around and my
girlfriend Whispers to me that's Briana
Stewart's wife the star of the liberty
and I turn around and I say you know if
you're anything like Brianna you're not
going to deliver tonight
so which I said as she walked away she
didn't hear but other people heard I got
to laugh that's a good line yeah she
boxed you out she boxed me out yeah wow
they take a car of Barclays dude I say
that really I've never been in there
we'll go we're going to we're going to
Knicks games this year I would love to
see but that's that's not at the
Barclays no it's MSG baby we're going
but I would I would go to a WNBA I could
I feel like I could keep up with it it's
fun man it's a fun it's a fun experience
they got Carbone in there you
get a little free Ron I've never eaten a
Carbone I tried to go twice couldn't get
in yeah I never I've never been to the
one in New York yeah I've been to the
Barclays one it's right there in the
village and I saw Schultz there with his
wife and they're like you cannot get in
and then Schultz looked at me and I went
ah I ran
away he was in there you know feet up
big like feeding his wife like a lady in
the Trap I was like God damn it couldn't
get it I had me and the lady had to walk
away yeah there's there's there's so
much good Italian though in New York
it's like some of that shit's over
overrated overpriced you know yeah yeah
I saw Kim Kay there once I mean
Kardashian yeah she was walking out of
there when she was still with Kanye they
were there together they got out of a
black car and I was like whoa and oh you
saw them you saw him walk in I saw him
walk in and cuz I couldn't get in so I
was waiting me it's like it's like uh
it's like a celeb spot I don't know if
it's as I think it's good but I don't
think it's as good as like the it's all
Buzz a lot of Buzz yeah which you know
that's part of the fun I guess but wow
WNBA that's cool how was how was Gavin
she was into it I I think I almost lost
it at one of her friends she was with
cuz someone was like sit down and I'm
like it's the playoffs you stand yeah
you stand on ke keepy also it's funny
that people little bossy you know what's
helping the WNBA is that they're like
psycho fans now ah cuz there was a guy
yelling at one of the women you
stink you and I was like that's
what they need that's equality that's
equality yes that's how we talk to the
men it's also funny that people think
they automatically assume that you're a
feminist if you go to these games but
you know there's dudes there who just
hate women right and it it was a cheap
ticket yeah he's just in there like you
make me a sandwich like oh
I hate my
mother I try to get my lady to watch and
she is she's like I won't do it and I'm
like the women are supporting now that's
the difference it's on them it's on them
it's all that's what I'm saying so I'm
like you want people to watch this you
have to watch it she's like I'd rather
watch The Bachelor you can't be a woman
who complains about inequality and
paying Sports and not support yeah
you're you're you're a hypocrite or
don't complain compl so she would not
watch it and I had this realization to
tell me this is is stupid she's like I
want to watch The Bachelor and I go why
she goes this is reality TV and I go but
this is actually edited that's reality
TV and just like a reality show it's a
bunch of women competing for a ring and
she didn't care I thought I had a good
point we should be dating we have the
we have fun yeah exactly if we
had vaginas and we better looking man
gays gays have got it made that's why I
want to just show women like look how
fun it could be if you weren't uh up our
asses all day we could all be in a glory
hole we could be blowing each other and
eating each other out we could all be
having sex 24/7 but you guys every
listeners all the women we just brought
in with that WNBA talk have just ex out
YouTube well we're trying to support it
you're going to gay I'm trying to get
the lady to watch it I just like sports
and I like New York Sports and I like
basketball I'm supporting but uh yeah I
think a lot of women can't relate you
you play basketball I grew up you know
shooting hoop with friends I don't think
you know my lady was like ever watching
or playing basketball in her life yeah
you got to support yeah but uh it needs
more drama they need like hair pulling
they need to cheat on a man there's some
drama they talk some okay you need
that's why that college basketball
was good with Caitlyn Clark where Angel
Reese they were like talking each
other blew up 55,000 people went to
watch Caitlyn Clark like there is a
future in this you just have to here's
the thing I get no one shits on Rogan by
the way people will on me if I
defend the WNBA cuz look it wasn't a
good League 10 years ago I'll give you
that it's getting good yeah no one shits
on Rogan for is he a fan no for pumping
up female
Fighters oh yeah but you should I I just
don't understand it I guess interesting
cuz that people I'm a UFC guy and no one
even bats an i we just watch them all no
one's like oh this is the female fight
that it's like no it's a good fight
so that is interesting because
basketball we go ah WNBA but the female
Fighters don't B the the competition was
not good I I'll give you that but it's
getting good I think the names would
help if they had funnier names I compare
it to like the the Cleveland uh or
whatever you know that would that would
help it the Indiana tampons yes yes the
Miami miscarriage something they got the
worst
mascot the bloody
head their careers on the
toilet um yeah man what what else you've
been up you been on the road uh been all
over the road how about this did
Portland Maine great do you do that
theater did that theater's incredible
the State Theater State Theater that's a
great one 1925 old as rickety cool
looking a lot of
patina I got heckled for an hour and a
half oh wow I don't know what it was
there it is beautiful room sold it out
and there's something about Maine it's
up there it's Ray Harrington has his
great bit about how Maine is is Canada's
Florida because it's like hanging off
the country it's like the south of the
north wow because they're like they're
wearing camo hats they hunt they're
Republican they're they're driving
trucks but then Portland's kind of
bougie but then Portland's bougie and
you got that Seafood it's like it's a
kind of a it's actually a vacation
destination it is it's huge and the
hotels are kind of very nice they say
more restaurants per capita in Portland
than anywhere else and the the the
cruises parked there and it's all
Lobster it's great it's like off
for
lobsters if you're a lobster get the
out of there they they are coming
for you that's true and uh we had
Lobster rolls in The Green Room of
course you got to do it up but yes it's
such a cool place it's a really pretty
city it's right on the water it's a lot
of like fishermen on heroin and tugboats
and all that good stuff a lot of LL
Bean you know a lot of Whitey but
there's something about Doug key went up
and Doug's funny Doug's great they were
just not having it they were like ah
what no boo heckling saying stuff and
he's like what are you guys doing I'm
I'm trying to do my act and like one
joke would hit then another one would
fall flat and he's great so it was he's
been touring with me for a while so I
knew it wasn't him and uh then I went up
and I had to just if I didn't if I
didn't keep my foot on the gas they
would yell any like free moment they
would yell so I was throwing people out
left to right you always have one of
those it's weird to have those in
theaters I actually I had a good one
there but I've had other ones on the on
this run that have been like wow that
was work you know yeah I think they
pregamed a little hard cuz they were
when I talked to the bouncer guys after
and they're like everybody we threw out
was like legless I was like all right
well that happened to me in Tulsa but I
ended up getting the gift of a guy just
so he was so shitfaced and he just kept
as he was getting tossed he just kept
screaming out gold so I was like
let him stay it was kind of funny and uh
ended up like getting him water then I
was like give him one more drink on
me you know but we ended up having fun
but they were bombed yeah the TOs to
that room have you done that Kane's Ball
Room I'm going there soon January epic
really I love it oh great all right and
and you got to hit up uh the DeMarco
slice the pizza place I I'll give you
the name it's killer all right I'm down
yeah one guy we threw out went and
bought merch from Doug and then put it
on and ripped it in front of him so they
metant business these guys that's like
the weirdest dick move ever yeah Doug's
like I got your money I don't give a
what you do with the shirt but yeah
that's like mean it's a little
aggressive but he paid for it he can do
it yeah but that's like
that's a dick it's a dick but he'll jizz
in it later anyway you know like it's
you know it's who knows where that
shirt's going he feels bad about himself
he goes home and he's like just
puts it around his neck hangs
himself so of course we go out we got
wrecked too drunk and then the next day
we drove we got in the car and drove
hung over like like this and drove to a
Providence and that was amazing love
Providence great Providence is like
weirdly kind of similar to Maine where
it's like there's like some really poor
Parts but then there's like really
bougie Parts yeah oh yeah Ro I got
Newport over there is incredible Hunter
Biden's got like a $3 million home there
oh really where you're like wait what
how is it and then you see it you're
like I I if you're on if you're on the
water you can charge like anything oh
yeah it's crazy they're like it's like a
crack house but they're like it's on the
water it's on the water yeah you can
puke right out the window and uh yeah
that was it is techically a crack house
if it's h bidens by the way ah good
point good point yeah Coke at the White
House the White House is now a Coke
house an app name I guess white house
but yeah then uh today or yesterday I me
and salacuse went and saw killers of the
flower Moon I saw it too I want to know
what you think all right uh I got to be
honest I didn't love it really okay I
liked it I didn't I got I got issues
with it all right well we'll get into it
let's get into it the best part of the
movie was salacuse was trying to buy a
flight he had a death in the family so
he's trying to buy a flight on the phone
I'm like why don't you just go online
he's like like I got to get the bement
fair so he's getting the bement fair
like a New York uh castanza
castanza yeah and so he's like yeah she
died two days ago I have the death oh
man great we were the only people in the
theater thank God really yeah he was
dead 1 p.m. there was one old couple in
the in the rafters but they were nine
one guy was sleeping I heard his snoring
it was a long movie it was very long I
thought it was really good I thought it
was great
salaku nailed it he said no tension you
know every scori movie you got you got a
Rota like oh the helicopters and we got
to make the sauce and you know they
you're you're up against it or the the
criminals are coming they're going to
murder us they're going to hit us with a
ballp hammer and put a head in Ace like
casino this was kind of just it it moved
but there was never those like rap
murder it's just a shot away you know
they're shooting a guy in the back of
the head a car blows up they push a guy
in a in a grave there wasn't that moment
of like it needed that opening ever
since I was young I wanted to steal
money from the oage Indians yeah exactly
they didn't have that but I thought it
was great and a a psychological Thriller
I mean I I got a lot of problems with it
please first off I love the book I said
this on the podcast before I love I
think David gr's an incredible writer
yeah to me in the book the most
interesting character by far is the
detective who is played by Jesse plens
the the bureau inspector sorry whatever
he didn't have a lot of development no
development he in in real life he's by
far the most interesting character I
mean he like had this crazy life story
he came from uh this interesting family
he had tension with uh with uh
God damn why is his name escaping with
Jay Edgar Hoover he oh really tension
with uh the FBI director so there he
like he wasn't accepted by cuz he wasn't
like an IV League you know buttoned up
guy he was more blue collar and that had
was interesting he did he did this
amazing case this was like that in the
book The Most Interesting parts are how
they prosecute and and develop and
you're basically getting it from A1
you're getting it from Ernest uh
burkhart's point of view who is a dumb
DiCaprio yeah he's a really he's a
thick character it's hard to like for me
like you bring bring up Good Fellas or
Casino those are smarter villains yeah
yeah so it's just kind of I'm just like
all right it's also 3 and 1 half hours I
I say with this type of movie you got to
make it either two and a half or make it
a miniseries man interesting
it's interesting to me that scors sey
who I love and I'm and I'm sure a lot of
people are going to disagree here but
he's like all about saving Cinema and
it's like you want to save it with a
three and a half hour Slow Burn that
I'll be honest if I didn't read the book
I would have been confused as by
this movie cuz they're just introducing
characters and not like kind of telling
who they are there's like all those
tertiary characters in the beginning
Barnaby comes in the detective comes in
he got well I don't want to say anything
but yeah you're right there's a lot of
people even with at one point I was like
who was that who got stabbed who was
that guy ex there's a lot of that and
and I was like if I didn't I don't know
I I would have been pretty confused it's
it looks beautiful beautifully shut and
beautifully edited and the actors are
great it's SC AC movie you know uh but I
got a beef with Frasier I thought
Brendan was weirdly over the top I'm
here to declare like what are you fogor
leorn take it easy in the courtroom I
think that's how they talked in the 20s
but it was weird yeah it was a weird
Choice it's also looked like I was like
man this guy did he keep the bodysuit
from the whale on when he came over here
he he looked he looked exactly the same
I thought he was going to jerk it to gay
porn at one point by the way Lily
Gladstone amaz such a subtle actor
anding her face would say so much those
eyes and everything it was really I've
never seen a she's going to win the
Oscar I'm calling her right now also I
don't know uh yeah I just I guess I just
didn't love it I don't know it's like
for me to do a three and a half hour
Slow Burn salaku yeah he's right there's
not a lot of tension there was a lot of
just kind of boring scenes and also the
way I don't want to give too much away
if you haven't seen it cuz there's stuff
I want to say but if you haven't seen it
it is still a new movie mhm I'm glad I
saw it just cuz it looked amazing and I
just wanted to know but I yeah I didn't
love it yeah all right that's I love
Stacy and I love his passion I think the
way he ended it I did I was like that
that was powerful that ending was badass
it was badass but I just
didn't I just think there's so much more
he could have done yeah and and I really
that was just such an undeveloped Jesse
plem is such a good actor and such a
good character and I wanted more of him
c yeah he was like I want say weak but
just there was not much to him at all he
was just the the long arm of the law and
also I think if you're going to write
characters who are this stupid and Evil
uh like Ernest Burkhart you know you
have to really expose their stupidity
and those were the funniest scenes like
there's a great
line where uh Jesse plem shows up and
I'm not giving anything away here but he
just you know his his character shows up
and he goes we're here to uh investigate
uh to look into the murders and and
Leonard DiCaprio's character goes what
about him and he goes who did him got a
big laugh in the theater it's just but
like that's the level of stupidity
you're dealing with I wanted more uh
that type of stuff cuz dealing with them
in court you're like wow they're
Sleazy and and dumb and sociopathic how
about the scene with that guy Lewis
kelman or whatever his name is where
he's like you realize you're saying
you're you're implying that you might
kill your kids to get the insurance
money and he's like well that's the
level stupidity you're dealing with evil
but also the real life uh the character
who Jesse plens plays in real life he uh
he had this crazy second chapter too
where he
uh after this he he ended up I think
being like I'm never going to move
up in the bureau so he ended up taking a
job as a prison Warden and he saw
William hail that like he was nice he
was nice to everyone yeah even if you
were in prison he was like he treated
with with respect there was a prison
breakout and these guys took him hostage
and shot him huh and he lived wow but he
was up from getting shot and he
was still nice to those people after he
brought them back to like he was just a
decent man yeah and and uh Hoover never
gave him his flowers ever oh really he
just like wasn't his type of dude he was
I think he saw him as more of a simple
guy but he was a pretty brave guy I
thought yeah well scors s didn't give
him his flowers either what the hell
that's what I'm saying and also I don't
know and he looks like if uh Matt Damon
got hit with a couple gamma rays he he's
character actor Damon for sure I know
it's a s fat Damon fat Damon my Norman
he's a great actor he's great he's
always great but uh also I thought
DiCaprio was getting a little borderline
Sling Blade in there at some point so
I'm like all right Easy Billy Bob you
got that that protruding chin and the
underbite a little hard but dude pull up
a picture of real life Molly Burkhart
and Ernest uh cuz you're going to be
like holy mhm like she's the
actress they got to play no no no go
down there's a better that one to the
right all the way to the right holy
top right top right like wow you don't
think this dude married you for
your money yeah I don't mean to be a
dick but holy this is some 90-day
fiance right here I mean you're
like that dude you're like yeah Leonardo
should play that dude yeah and then
you're like who should play her I don't
know Danny
tro the hell is going on here this is
this is brutal I mean like terrible life
I feel my heart goes out to her they
were tough people she was getting poison
the the diabetic uh it's uh you know
yeah they're stealing the money all
their family dies well I don't want to
give much away but I mean it's a really
insane what they had to to to get to be
lucky enough to get that wealth and then
you just get murdered yeah I know the
white man yeah but the white man
saved we had both sides of the cin we're
very complex race everything's complex
yeah he was a handsome guy so they they
it's a good good casting wow I didn't
know Danny tryo boy that is really
something you nailed it on that
one who's I think uh Hispanic but it
worked yeah that if we really break that
one down it might be racist so let's
leave that alone ah you're fine you're
fine it's a perfect call I got a you got
any I got peeves oh I love I love still
having a tryo cuz I was sitting there
trying to think of who you could use and
you hit it right on the
bullseye all right here we go peeves I
got a couple of bangers I think I
hope um all right this is annoying this
this might get weird but uh you ever
have this one you go uh hold on I go uh
that guy that guy we just met was he gay
and then I had the lady be like some
random woman was like oh what do you
mean is he gay what's wrong with being
gay I'm like I'm not saying there's
anything wrong with being gay I'm asking
if he is gay and she's like I don't know
what are you saying all gay guys are
alike I'm like I'm saying I don't know
if he's gay if they were all alike I
would know that he was gay and we're
like getting into it and I'm like what
is this where we pretend to not
not people don't have like you know
qualities that make you cuz we have
gayar right but then if you go was he
gay she was she just lost it on me she
was like who lost who was this it was
this like a Comics girlfriend and I'm
like I'm asking was she gay no she was
the girlfriend of a a male comedian and
I'm like I'm just asking asking was he
gay and she's like well how would I how
would I know I'm like well some people
have better gatar I have no gar and she
was like well who cares if he's gay I'm
like I'm just curious if he's gay and
it's just weird like Bill Burr has that
great joke where he's talking about like
a super Butch lesbian and a woman's like
what do you mean and he's like you know
what you're picturing that you know it
like it BM it pisses me off that she's
acting like there's never been a gay guy
who's like hello and we all go okay that
guy's gay and I'm not saying that's bad
I'm just saying some gay guys can be
more flamboyant everybody knows that I
couldn't tell I'm asking if he was G
asking about a person I don't like I
don't get why that's offensive yeah we
we got into it damn that's it's weird to
be offended by a I mean I know I don't
get that I'm just curious is he gay you
know then she's like why do you care I'm
like maybe I'll hit on him you know like
how do you know I'm not into him I need
to know if he's gay before I hit on him
it it it's always like some implic like
so you hate them like no I'm I'm hanging
out with them it's the same tone of like
smugness as those people who are like uh
the doctor and you're like oh what did
he say she said and you're like all
right you're a better person than me I'm
sorry you're you're more tolerant right
right there probably are more are more
male doctors in America so you went with
the odds I also I'm a guy I just it's
not it's just I'm a man so I say that
because I know more men than women right
it's not the the worst is when you uh by
the way if you said serial killer what
was a cereal was he blonde they never go
sh it's only for doctors and but
the worst when you do it to a dog and
somebody flips out you're like I don't
give a if the dog's a guy or girl
oh what's his name her name it's a shihu
it shits on the floor I'd love to kick
it in the face Winnie dude Miss
Winnie got to bring Winnie back I like
her all right she yeah she's very fun
yeah and a big hit in the comments by
the way people love W people want more
Winnie dude M oh yeah not a big hit with
your cat unfortunately but you know we
uh is that cat gay no I'm kidding I got
I got peeves let me see what I got I
know I got some peeves I got lots of
peeves yeah it always goes to hate oh uh
I got another one too what I got
um people
people people who are who are
and victims that's my opin good
when you say something shitty and then a
person reacts and then they're like oh
no oh you really hurt me with how you
reacted I'm just like wait but you said
the mean thing there's a term for this
online it's called cry bully oo yeah
they they're mean and then when you give
it back to them they cry damn so they
always win they get to be mean and they
get to be coddled o pretty Brant it's
also uh people who a lot of liberals do
this where they where they poke you and
then you respond and they're just like I
don't want to I don't want to talk about
that and you're like but you brought it
up you brought it up so true it's like
they get to get their shot in and then
you're like you just hit me and they're
just like I'm I'm going in the other
room right right yeah yeah it's so true
my brother used to do that he was such a
fighter he would hit you and then
you'd hit him back and he was
like I like what the hell you hit me so
yeah I'm totally with you on that one
that's no good oh my God cry bully there
it is it's in the Urban Dictionary folks
my mom did this to me she came to the
cellar with me and my mom does and I'm
not call my mom the seword by the way I
was saying in a more General sense but
my mom uh watched my set I'm getting a
woman's talking my entire set at the
comedy Celler and I'm doing a long bit
that I can't really bail out of these
momentum so I had to just kind of power
through and then at the end of the
bitette I get my pop and I go you going
to talk the whole show yeah kind of like
say it and she kind of then is like
bails off and I and I get a couple lines
zinging her and then I you know I go
into an abortion joke and I kind of
pause I'm like you know that thing you
should have been and it get get my get
my quick laugh and I move on and it's
fine but she's annoying and Val the
manager at the Celler goes in they're
like sure sure and I get off stage and
my mom goes you're mean and I was like
your mom said that you're starting with
a drunk Heckler over me and my mom's
like you just hand her in a very mean
way Val over here it and Val goes no he
handled that very well actually all
right my mom goes I don't want to I
don't want to talk I'm like you just
call me mean yeah also where's the
backup mom you're on my team you should
be hating this lady with me wow I'm I'm
shocked yeah I was
bummed damn come on Mom yeah and she
started it this other lady she started
it I know it's just you could have been
a lot meaner you could have gone in on
her he did one line and got out I I just
said to her I was like you know how many
years I've done the road like you think
I would have survived D in papered strip
malls if I didn't have like the you know
ability to do crowd control a little bit
you got you got to turn it on course
yeah no that I'm with you on that one
yeah thank you come on hear that Mom
yeah we'll get her on here and really
ber
her we sit her down she's like no I'm
not I can't I yeah no we we're we're all
fans I love you Mom I love you Mom we're
good we we patch it up well that's the
thing if you talk during a show like
you're you're open now you're exactly
you're a Target so that's on you yeah
all right how about this peeve hold
on all right what is it farting in
people's faces is that the
peeve um if it's not I got one coming
up
okay hey we might be drunk is brought to
you by factor it's the age of
convenience baby we're constantly trying
to save time whenever we can with Factor
America's number one ready to eat meal
kit you'll never have to cook again talk
about a game changer Factory delivers
Chef prepared dietician approved meals
straight to your door they're always
fresh never Frozen just heat them up in
two minutes and dinner served choose
from over 35 weekly meal options with
fall favorites like cranberry pecan
chicken apple Dijon pork chops with so
many options as something for everybody
and the whole family will love it
Factor's awesome I can't cook these
things right to my house it's amazing
I'm always on the go they're quick they
taste great and I'm not getting a ton of
vegetables but with factor I am and they
got vegie sorry vegan vegetarian keto
calorie smart Protein Plus no matter
what your goals are they can get you
there head toctor meals.com drunk 50 and
use code drunk 50 to get 50% off half
off that's huge that's code drunk 5@
Factor meals.com
drunk Z to get 50% off do it
today that's a these are good deals yeah
they're half off's huge between the
holiday shopping the cooking and the
gift wrapping things can get Crazy Fast
ship station is here to save you time
with your small business so you can
focus on the people and the Traditions
that make the season so special ship
station is shipping software that makes
order fulfillment and processing returns
a breeze with industry leading
discounted rates on USPS UPS DHL and
mobile post you'll save tons on shipping
costs and ship station effortlessly
manages orders prints labels Compares
rates and automates delivery
notifications it's truly a One-Stop shop
for a smooth workflow got to use this it
makes your life much easier uh if any of
your customers have returns to make ship
station automates the process recommends
exchanges and even gathers customer
feedback let your customer shop
risk-free this holiday with shipstation
go to shipstation.com and use code drunk
today and sign up for your free 60-day
trial that shipstation.com Cod drunk
nice shipstation.com Cod drunk get on
it the two words he could have done it
we didn't even have a guess this week he
couldn't have done it that way oh he had
to do it right into my tried to keep it
neutral I could have done this but yeah
oh Jesus Christ no I wouldn't do that to
you so this is Gaza and I'm flam right
now two words full full stop I'm so sick
of full stop so that's my views on
Ukraine they shouldn't be whatever
haahah Russia's a superpower Putin's
evil full stop you could just stop yeah
wait what is that you've never heard
full stop yeah I know I have but I don't
get is is that like a
period I don't know I don't know I what
are we doing just you can just stop you
don't have to say full stop it's like
reading a telegram in like the 30 or yes
exactly
so and so needs more medicine period
space new paragraph no just just stop
talking you know what is it's kind of
like on social media when people I guess
it was mostly Twitter when people would
do like the the claps we need to stop a
part High put claps in between and
you're like well that tweet will do it
yeah good job I hate the what do people
expect I don't know what they they're
like they're like I did it I know that's
by the way that's activism now of course
is someone is just people used to have
to like put on a a suit and go to
Mississippi in this filtering heat now
they're just like I'm sad send yes
exactly my work's done yeah these
atrocities need to end full stop thank
you lady at Coffee
Bean now it's it's out of control but
you know there's a great video of a guy
who goes to a campus and he's one of
these with the uh the
microphone in your face and he's like do
you think illegal immigrants should be
allowed in college and every student is
like 100% he's like well who's going to
pay for it and they're like they'll find
somebody to pay for it and he goes well
we actually started a fund if you want
to give money and they all go ah I got
to get out of here so he's like he's
basically just showing like you you talk
a big game but you're not actually
willing got my mom she was like AB nope
I I got to yeah she's like you're
mean I do hate the uh that gotcha I
hate the gotcha too on both sides I
got a good pee for you all right um all
right people at the gym who are filming
if you you want to just film yourself
don't put me in the shot oh yeah
I got I got was in someone's shot
recently I didn't find out till I got
tagged on Instagram really this guy had
a decent amount of followers so it's
like and by the way he they always look
like a superhero you never look at your
best no he's Bing 500 lb I'm behind him
scratching my ass I'm like well glad
this one got all these clicks you yeah
wellow pull that up if you can I don't
even know where it is did you reshare it
I don't know where it is I'm sure I
could find it actually oh that's funny
yeah enough with the gym filming just go
work out we need content at the gym it's
for some people are like monitoring
their progress and that's I think that's
fine I don't care and also if you if
that's your page some people are like
you know
uh people post that the way we post our
standup you know if that's your whole
thing but you're supposed to be filming
a standup show and it's our theater show
like we're the headliner this is a full
public gym if you want to do that go to
a any Time Fitness at 4:00 a.m. when you
have the whole place to yourself and and
set up a full rig and lights and a get a
boom guy and a director go nuts yeah but
enough with this now using up two
machines cuz one is the camera thing and
then the other one is you using the
machine it's it's too much yeah but
peeves are good man you get this out you
feel good you go about your day yeah I
got another one please when I'm at
killers of the flower moon uhhuh is this
no way I'm in this is this another one
no no I'm not in this oh I want to see
you struggling this dude I would have
remembered Sam's in a black socks he's
got like dress socks on and a and a
weird t-shirt and I want to see you like
trying to put the 25 pound thing on the
bar you know not even the machine uh I
had another one so I'm at uh I'm at
kills the flower Moon I'm with my mom we
see the movie and
uh you know you have to select the seats
now it's not like old days showed up no
I'm not in this one dude I I don't know
where it I I got I didn't get like tag
tag I got someone commented my name so
that's why I saw it
but
um so you have to pick your seats right
yeah it's a pretty we saw it was a
pretty full theater uh and we go uh we
get to our seats there's jackets all
over our seats and I I kind of say does
this belong to anyone here cuz I think
these are our seats and this old couple
in the row in front turn around like
like annoyed ah they like get up annoyed
like GH and she it took forever to move
them I'm like how hard is this
yeah you know she moves and then and
then no no like oh sorry about that like
just like oh we wanted more seats well
then buy the seats it's just out
of control I can't stand people doing
up and then getting mad at
when you call them on it I know that's
the whole society cry bullies cry bully
completely and we need a drill sergeant
to come in there with a whistle
and crazy arms and be like shut the
up apologize to him we need somebody to
keep these people in check cuz they just
keep doing it we need that guy from the
college campuses with a mic do you think
this is okay yes yes bring it's okay
well I was talking to list and he
figured out how he got Co he was at
Chipotle and this lady kept coughing and
coughing like big wet loud cough and he
kind of gave her one of these and she
was like everywhere I go people give me
dirty looks I'm coughing I'm allowed to
cough and you're like and then she goes
you should get a mask and he's like
you're coughing why am I the bad guy and
by the way that person like is co is co
you're not you're not you don't just
have Co you're Co yes yes you're a
pandemic you're ruining lives and uh but
that's where we're at like the lady with
the or the guy with the boom box on the
bus and just blaring it and you're like
he could you turn that down he's like
you man I do what I do and you're
like why am I bad you're you got a boom
box people just Snee a guy nearly
sneezed on me the other day in the
street and I I I wasn't even mad I
actually started laugh I'm like it's
just so gross you start laughing like
you're such garbage I know no
covering the mouth those are my favorite
people the people just sneezing into the
air yeah you're not even covering your
mouth and what is going on with men's I
don't know how you sneeze but I try to
keep a dull Roar but my dad's
like is that necessary like birds are
flying like out of a tree when you
sneeze oh that guy just poked his head
out I think I scared him Tarzan yeah I'm
like what is that you need to do that
where the the birds flap away from the
building but here's one more peeve and
then we'll move it along oh we got this
by the way a real estate novelist is a
writer who specializes in crafting
stories around the buying selling or
flipping properties all right riveting
stuff yeah that's why he's at the bar JK
Rowling over there all right yeah that's
why he's at the bar drinking his sorrows
away because nobody's buying his
paperback on uh condos
so last peeve then we'll move it along
by the way the peeves are a big hit I
get a lot of people do like a Q&A people
like peeves people just yell peev and I
don't know what to say um okay first of
all electric vehicles are a nightmare I
I've using couple openers who will rent
an electric vehicle they're like hey I
picked up a rental car got half off for
an EV and I'm like you got cuz
all our whole whole trip is now revolved
around charging this thing cuz we're
going like a you know a two-hour drive
and they just they just plummet in
energy when you do the highway you know
just woo that energy bar is going down
so we're always like well we'll get an
ice cream and let it show oh well go go
to the comic book store and read a
couple of Spidermans I'm like what are
we doing we could have been there by now
but that's the EV for you so the
electric car is just it just has Todd
Barry's voice I'm not driving anymore
dog I'm done exactly this is a super
secret Car drop in so so we pull up to
the EV place the charging station which
is always out in the burs it's by a Red
Robin and uh and all that you know
by a Ruby Tuesday and it's a Concrete
junk
you got the 12 Tesla Chargers they're
all full and there's a line so we're
like God not only is the charge a half
hour but the line's 20 minutes so now
we've lost an hour doing this so
this lady pulls up in front of us and
goes right to the charging station and
we're waiting in line clearly and then
we're kind of giving her like the we're
in line and she backs it up and now
we're window to window and she goes are
you in line and we're like yeah she goes
all right I'll wait then like oh oh oh
thank you for doing exactly the rules
what do you mean you like she said it
like all right I'll be a good person and
wait like no that's how lines work we
were here a half hour before you you
crazy C you broke the rules and now you
on credit for not breaking the rules
that's a better way to put it thank you
no people are awful the worst
I'll get we'll get in line behind you
then yes that's how it goes this City's
I'll tell you everywhere people no
manners there no decency I I
nearly got hit by a guy this
I told you hate the bikes in New
York this guy whizzes by me and he
is on his phone he almost hit me
cuz he's on his phone I had a
green light yeah 100% his fault and I go
what the yes and he turns around he
goes you and go that's what it took
for him to I was like Wow stop talking
on the phone I really got to start
macing as they go by I
love to see him fly through a
windshield well they keep getting away
with it so there's no uh there's no
repercussions I will do prayers at night
that he ends up paralyzed yeah I
I pray it'll happen if you keep biking
in this city that way he won't be able
to look at his
phone well he'll look at in the hospital
bed when he's got the a nurse is holding
he's like ah thank God thank you he's
like swiping right with his nose cuz his
whole body's banged up yeah it's the
next step and yeah we're going to go
backwards in evolution guy like that's
true yeah well you ever see a w- I
haven't seen it I heard it's amazing
brilliant brilliant movie Pixar always
kills it but the whole thing is at the
end Wally gets up to the spaceship and
it's just fat people in chairs who like
are drink smooth or uh Slurpees and
frosties all day and don't want to work
and they nailed it it's great it's just
all screens then the screens go down and
they're like what do I do and they try
to walk but they're too fat it's great
it's just called the Minneapolis
Airport wo that's really what
they when people were like oh my God
this is like you you ever trying to run
to get a connect flight and you're just
like weaving through people people it's
like you feel like you're on one of
those like old Nickelodeon yes game
shows totally like with the the one with
the Supermarket Sweep you got your
luggage just cutting through porkers all
day that it show but that show like
should just have like people in it you
have to get around people too that's
true goddamn but yeah a lot of airport
running people have seen me running like
comedy whizzing by and I give it one of
these but you you can't stop oh you're
done yeah yeah it's a it's a wild world
out there but I think as a road comic
you can't be too big you got to be
nimble I'm running down Subway stairs
I'm jumping on trains I feel like John
Wick out here it's tough to you know cuz
I I like to I like to have a drink but
yeah got to make sure to hit the gym too
just to like not to yeah to be able to
to move a little I know I felt bad cuz
you know Maine was such a slugfest
comedically and then we got shitfaced
just to get through it then where I'm
like banged up one of those oldfashioned
2008 hangovers in Providence where I was
like I can't move I really can't move I
got in the hotel I just laid down for a
while and I'm like this sucks for the
Providence crowd cuz I'm all shitty I'm
like I'm like 50% of my normal self so I
had to I drank like eight coffees a Diet
Coke and I got a green juice and I made
made myself do push-ups I'm sweating out
tequila and then I just went out there
and tried to bring it you have to just
like trick yourself in that you're not
that up I it's weird cuz coffee
is what I do when I when I'm hung over
too but what what's helping you is also
hurting you you're getting more
dehydrated true but yeah I need I need
to fight it I know it does give you a
little brain relief like the my head
hurts less when the coffee but my body's
still wrecked it's like different
anxiety it really is a caffeine anxiety
instead of Hangover which I'd rather
have the caffeine anxiety than the it
ain't going to work out anxiety hangover
and I feel I can see myself on stage I'm
like a second slower you know like oh if
I was not hung over I could have thought
of something here but you're just a
little foggier with the hangover yeah
it's a little tougher you need that
brain moving you know firing at all
synapses or whatever the hell you know
you know what I was watching the other
day have you ever seen this movie uh old
Mammoth movie called House of games no
it's with young Joe montania and Linds
Krauss no it's good house of
games what's what's the Rotten Tomatoes
it was good I call that a dve and
Busters House of games yeah it's it's
good oh wow 97% it's uh it's slick it's
about it's about conmen okay I like com
is cool as it all right I don't
even know who Lindsey Krauss is yeah I
text list about it and he goes one of my
favorites yeah it was a cool movie I
know the game with Shawn Penn another
great movie Fincher finer
dude yeah so good I told you my finer
story no oh I think I I must have told
you this I worked on Benjamin buttons as
you did tell me okay yeah PA and I got
to see him fire a guy I forgot that was
Fincher yeah threw the Hat down like out
of a movie the whole thing stepped on it
God you'll never work in this town again
the guy was like I'm so sorry Mr F he's
like get out of my sight I never want to
see you again that whole thing it was
awesome and then he pushed him off a
building it was all a game yeah yeah
damn yeah oh yeah then I had to get his
coffee after and I was trembling like
here you go sir I was like 19 years old
how does he take his coffee ah I
think I just got him a black coffee from
I respect a black coffee drinker yeah
it's always I feel like a lot of people
for some reason a lot of famous people
they like put a lot of sugar in it or
Splendor whatever the hell and I'm like
how the hell do you do cuz those are
people who have like cream and sugar and
then they have like eight a day I'm like
so you're just having a a bucket of
cream every day I know it's it's crazy
my buddy worked on a Michael Bay movie
and he said he was the I don't want to
put this out in the world but he said he
had to have a two espresso shots bone
dry something milk and two two raw
sugars bone dry something give that a
goo bone dry coffee I can't remember how
to determine out but he's he says it all
the time when I see him bone dry cppo
bone dry cappuccino with two espresso
shots and Two
Sugars bone dry has no steam milk
between the foam and the coffee layer
it's just a thick foam layer on top of
man famous people are weird yeah they
really want their thing I just am like
coffee just get me and people like I I
don't know I'll just drink it black then
it's fine yeah I'll put a little milk in
usually but like who gives a I know
but I think part of it is just let me
just see if you listening and if you
give a enough to do what I
said how important am I kind of thing
or some of those dudes are just really
picky I think I think they're like some
of these people that made it to a crazy
level are obsessive about every detail
yeah and that's another thing they're
obsessive about but that's what's great
about being a comedian even if you get
to I'm sitting there with Colin Quinn
and Jim Norton last night before what
Nate was going on and Colin Quin was
everything Norton said he was like shut
up you know and you're like you need
that you know Norton's a big comic yeah
but he'll never get to this bone dry
cappuccino place cuz he'll have Colin
Quinn's voice in his head going bone dry
who do I think I am Frank
Sinatra it is good to have friends
voices in your head making fun of you
for being a piece of oh yeah I mean
don't you have that every time I'm at a
cool clothing store I'm in the dressing
room and I just hear Ari you know going
what the Keith yeah you can't wear
that stupid you think I can pull that
off you need a combination of like a
support system but also like ball
busting yes you need people that are
like have your back back but also will
like be like you're a idiot
right keep you in check and balances you
need both yeah there's something about I
don't know I lost what I was
going to say I had something well you
need a little fun every now and then
every now and then buy that leather
jacket or whatever yeah no look we're on
stage every night we should look
presentable but that you do need that
voice yeah keeping you down a little I
think there's something about also LA or
or cities that are more isolated where
you just don't true it's what are you
going to get ball busted over speaker
phone and your Corvette it's like you
got to you got to be around people and
because cities you know like New York
are so densely populated like you're on
top of each other so you do I mean I
said you to a guy today on the
street oh there you go I mean like was
that the bike yeah I mean you you and he
said it back I mean we cursed at each
other and it was like all right I mean
for better or worth wor worse I
can't speak for better or worse we're
kind of like stuck in this you know with
our neighbors yeah and that's you're
going to have the good and the bad then
La you're just you're in your car too
much com ball bust in completely yeah
you're in your apartment then you're in
your car listening to what you want to
listen to with your exact climate then
you go to your whatever work or you
might work from home you're never
amongst the masses and New York New York
will keep you it's all masses well
you're right in La it's like you're in
your car welcome to Fresh Air with Terry
G in New York in New York you're on the
subway some guy goes on shut the up
some crazy guy screaming by the way
there's a type of uh of of whatever fedl
whatever drugs people are on the street
there's a type that makes you like a
there's like The Conspiracy Theory batch
have you seen that I saw a guy on the
street just like muttering he's like
Espionage I'm like what the oh I've
seen that guy you got the you
got the bad I feel like even if you get
sober you're going to be annoying right
you like one of those yeah even if you
get sober best case he's like he's like
a he he cleaned up up his act like
what's he doing mostly on Reddit mostly
on Reddit talking about Epstein killed
himself but yeah but even La they have
all they have more homeless than us but
they got them all in one spot whereas
our hobos are peppered throughout the
city you can catch a hobo on the Upper
West Port Authority Wall Street we're
all over they're like
landmines you can't you can't uh Dodge
one La they you know where they're
coming cuz there's like a tent and they
like pop out all right they set they set
up camp here right yeah new La is like
uh you know Kurt Russell Escape From LA
right and then and then New York is more
just like all right they've integrated
their yeah it's more like Frogger like
oh there's one over here there's one
over there there you're like skid R Done
stimulation yeah there tons of
stimulation but I think you're right I
think you you take the go with the bet
you need a you every now and then
and uh it's good it's it's good for you
like I'm mad in the moment but then a
lot of times I realize more and more
like when I'm mad in the moment it's
going to lead to a bit like disc Comfort
is I think actually good for your life
oh 100% yeah you had I had that moment
on the flight recently you have that
moment on the flight where you land and
then you're just on the runway yeah and
you're mad cuz it's but it's
funny it is funny but at the time you're
like of course but when you take
yourself out of it you're like it's
funny that I just landed from Portland
Oregon yes and we're here and I can't
move like you have to you have to
distance yourself enough to be like this
is a funny thing that's true once you're
in the cabul gets funny but right right
right no that that's a good point oh I
had something you brought something up
and it made me think of something yeah
you got all the way across the uh the
country and now you're I'm drinking
salices now do it do it him yeah
well you know he's not here snooze you
lose oh I can't remember my Portland
point but I lost it but yeah something
about something about uh but this is
this is what New York does to you one
time I was in the way of the door or
something I was like really into a pod
on my earbuds and uh this big guy at the
end of of the car goes hey curly hair
move and I was like oh jeez sorry I
didn't know all these people were mad at
me I was like so in this in my own head
but even somehow curly hair hurt my
feelings I have curly hair I'm fine with
curly hair but just the guy going hey
curly hair I like I was like oh that
kind of hurt a little but that's what
that's what a intent can do or tone can
do you you're demasculate I mean there's
like a moment where you're like there's
more to me than that yes yes ex but this
guy doesn't know that yeah and in in
hindsight he could have been like hey
homo hey white boy hey hey que
white boy would have hurt us badly
though yeah I don't love white boy yeah
yeah I guess I grew up with white boy
when that connotation is negative yeah
yeah I guess there's nothing good but I
am a white boy hey buddy buddy's not
badad Buddy's not bad but even with the
right tone Buddy's like oh buddy
can suck yeah you have that guy oh I
used to have a guy hey buddy I was like
GH yeah yeah you feel wet after someone
says not the good kind of wet like
that's true you're like the
buddy yeah I don't love that yeah but
curly hair sucks I know and and there's
nothing wrong I'm not ashamed of my hair
curly would have been worse Curly's
worse
curly that's true hey curly why is Curly
bad cuz he didn't have time to say hair
yeah yeah curly
hair that's true I'm trying to think of
like things that would hurt if someone
yelled well if you were like hey Mexican
is way worse than hey Mexican guy
neither you don't want to say that to
anybody but like you're like hey Mexican
hitting them with a group is is rough
and that that's like fighting words
almost but I think this guy was somewhat
trying to be efficient yeah and and
cordial like hey you with the curly hair
but he just said hey curly hair but at
at the time I was still like ah that
that stung a little but he was he's not
wrong so that's funny it's
something about it it was funny later I
realized that was funny having to get
people's attention I mean
yeah I had I had won this is a peeve man
we're peeve heavy this week aren't we
it's been a while since it's been just
me and Mark so yeah we're getting it all
out I had a guy you have the guy like
say what's up to
you um at at a show and you're like yeah
what's up how are you and and and then
you see him again a few blocks later and
they're just like walking with you and
you're like is this guy going to
walk into my Lobby I know I know just
he's just like yeah so yeah you're back
there and you're like how long's this
going to go I have this I have that all
the time cuz I don't know you right I
don't know if you're crazy yes and we're
all fine with the how you doing hey
let's chat it up but it's the what's the
shot clock on this cuz this could go for
three days that's what you need you need
an interaction shot clock a buzzer needs
to go off totally like uh like the
Oscars speech we need a guy to be like
you know we need the orchestra to start
playing we need the and you're like all
right we're going this way now yeah yeah
right right exactly and break all right
we need the Blackjack guy to go you're
done with the uh the small talk do you
gamble at the casinos I dabble for me
gambling is like uh eating pizza at 2
a.m. if I'm drunk I'm all over it and I
went to skankfest and you drink all
night you know everything's a party and
you're staying in a Cino Hotel so you
get you're like I'm going home I'm going
to be a good Bo was it which casino was
it the Golden Nugget so not even a good
Casino yeah but that's you know what's
good about casinos like that is the
gambling's pretty cheap that's true they
got some cheap tables that's true like
Vegas Vacation it was like uh 50 cents
for what is it paper rock scissor game
and then uh what what what number am I
thinking of was a game it was really
funny but uh I get out of this strip
club it's 4 in the morning I'm like I'm
going to bed before the sun comes up I'm
hammered I've been doing shots all night
I get to the casino the two areu garbage
guys are at the crafts table they're
like Norman and I'm like woo $300 throw
it down give me that my my big stack of
chips I'm throwing around I'm tipping
the waitress she's bringing drinks I'm
high-fiving people it's like a montage I
was like Sharon Stone throwing the chips
up cut to 7 a.m. I'm out of money I owe
him 200 now I'm down five and I'm still
awake cut to 7:00 a.m. you're in the
Boiler Room you're tied to a chair
you're begging for your life yeah heads
in a iice yeah no it's really uh it's
really fun but at a certain point I hate
losing money that I worked for of course
it's cuz I don't I feel way worse when I
lose and I feel good when I win yes I'm
like who cares I didn't this is
all and I it gets to a point
when I get drunk where I just I'm like
it I throw it all down yeah and
that's where you're like oh wow I'm dumb
this is money I this is totally money
and The House Always Wins would feels
better than a craps win is a sports win
cuz at least you got to sit in the game
and you got like a 3 hour that I would
I've done a few times and that's way
more fun because I'm sitting in the
sports book with eight guys in a leather
chair drinking Bud Lights going oh go go
go go he did it and so it's a win and a
win you get the money and the game was
awesome I do it a little it's crazy that
the Middle East is on FanDuel now you
can get you pick a side I I thought it
was in poor taste but uh no it's I don't
really do it but I should it's it's fun
and it's also like it makes games you're
like kind of into way more fun baseball
playoffs is fun I'm in I'm in oh
yeah and it's like they got Jeter now
doing the uh really they got him doing
the booth and it's Jeter A-Rod and Ortiz
and you're like this is good for
baseball to have those names and we can
all hear about them spit roasting
Madonna let's get into that talk too how
many of you have been in
Madonna no uh it it's good and it's and
you throw a little money down I don't do
it enough because I actually just like
watching but you're right it would take
it to the next level yeah yeah I would
bet with my heart though that's the pro
I'm too much of a ncks fan that I would
like I would up and bet with my
heart it's true it really makes you
judge a team like all right this guy's
wife's pregnant he's uh he's been
drinking a little he's on a blow charge
you know I was just watching uncut gems
cuz was on TV the other day again and
like just how much he knew like oh my
God just to be that level like that you
know what's crazy that movie stresses me
the out it's a great movie talk
about tension but it stresses me out
yeah and it's not me and it's not even a
real character but I'm stressed out I
know but that was that's a hat off hat
tip to the filmmaking the safty brothers
they're amazing amaz with the the buzzer
and then they letting him in he's like
hey the door's not working all that
just compounding amazing how scary uh
bagian is yes yes and Reggie is it
Reggie Miller not Reggie Miller Garnett
Garnett he's great in that movie he's
great the guy's wife is or the
girlfriend's some dude he's got
so much going on it's it's great
just that that type of line must be so
stressful cuz there's people like that
who exist who just lie to the point
where you're like how do you f we know
some of those types of people showas
obviously but like their whole life is
just like they I would be stressed all
the time if I just imagine like
just lying to everyone oh just like this
is worth this don't worry the money's
coming yeah everything everything don't
the money's like people we've worked
with like the check's in the mail and
you're like I don't think people do that
anymore I know I think they just wire
they're like it's in the mail
I've gotten some DMS where they're like
I bought your merch it never showed up
and I'm like whoa really I feel so bad
I'm like how long's it been they're like
I got it yesterday I'm like well it's
mail give two weeks at least and then DM
me you scared the out of me I
thought you were going to come to my
house with a bat you know but yeah
people get people get worked up you
start to realize why companies now you
can't even call them everything's
automated they're
like if you'd like assistance try our
website you're like what the let me
just talk to somebody but it's people
are too nutty I think it's hard to talk
to everybody yeah people are losing it
yeah I think every once in a while you
ever get like a person on the phone and
they're like and you're like in a bad
mood but they're crazy and you're like
this ain't going anywhere no no it's
just two heads button cuz you get I mean
some of those people are like so
understanding like Louis had that great
bit remember like like I don't want this
woman in India to do my Airline call
like I want some fat woman from
Texas how are you sugar yeah you want
that lady yeah she doesn't care about my
problems and right right but uh it's so
true you just want you got to get the
right person man he had some oh
yeah he some classics classics I
actually saw him yesterday walking I saw
the movie and he was walking through the
village I haven't seen him forever he
looked amazing really he was like thin
he had a cool outfit on he had like a
corduroy green jacket with boots and he
had lenen glasses on like the circular
ones I was like who are you yeah he
dressed as kind of cool yeah he had a
lady with them too I might say yeah it's
funny when you see those guys they're
kind of like especially in that they're
in that period of their lives where
they're just like like all the fashion
stuff kind of comes together you see
like Lou or like Chris Rock you're like
that's a cool jacket I know
little little Moola goes a long way and
he was he seems centered he was like hey
how are you man I haven't seen you in a
while and I was like oh hey
hey CU anyone you on both cheeks like
what the is he's French now yeah
he's but he looked great and uh he was
in a great mood and I I was like I just
saw the score he's like it's great right
it's great he got all into it I was like
oh yeah yeah couldn't wait to get out of
there I wish I liked him more I didn't
hate it I just was like I I I just wish
he went a different way with it but but
I also love scorsi and I love his
passion like did did he come on before
the screen right he comes on before the
movie I love how much he pours into it
but 100% And I do think in his old age
because what is he 80 80 he's 80 so I
think in his old age as you get older
and kind of more relaxed and lowkey his
movies have you know like like the
Irishman is so long and drawn out and
this that's my point it's like it's
weird that they're now all so long I
know cuz I think it's like almost like
an old person your stories get longer
and you but like that's not a good thing
no my grandpa was a better Storyteller
in his 70s than he was at 88 yeah you
know what I mean point you lose that
edit button I think well yeah it's like
a Biden speech you know it's a little
over here a little over there it's the
same thing yeah you're you're right with
the age comes the longer story The more
boring story and he's a legend more and
more so you're getting less nose that's
a good point so maybe the edit button is
a little less frequent yeah I don't know
editor old too Delma shoe maker or
whatever her name is shoe maker who's
great yeah they age together they're is
it is it top five score Stacy for you
it's not for me top five well now we got
to do top five yeah but uh well you got
Taxi Driver Raging
Bull uh Good Fellas hard not to put
those three automatically in that's four
wait what was it Taxi Driver Raging Bull
Good Fellas
and uh casino's not my five oh wait I
guess you're right that is three um what
else what else you got Casino gangs in
New York
departed I love The Departed like just
in terms of in terms of rewatch Factor
the departed's incredible I love
Cape Fear I love a I watched Kate Kate
fur's got crazy good rewatch value too
great great talk about tension tension
and it's like it's kind of funny in dark
yeah that's what I mean like this one's
a hard one to add humor to cuz it's such
a morbid yes but he always punches in a
little bit of humor uncut gims no he's
the producer oh okay uh yeah we got to
go direct W wall Street's pretty good
Wolf of Wall Street's great yeah that
was like his
last I feel like banger well that was
like a you were talking about like
slower Pace that was fast pace yeah
that's true I dude I love shudder Island
but I don't it's not my top no but I do
love it Taxi Driver might be number one
in my mind or or Raging Bull is is
amazing God hard not to a Good Fellows
one also dude I wouldn't say it's one of
his best but it's hard for me not to put
after hours in my to I love that movie
amazing that's like so unlike him too
yeah king of comedy's Great's great yeah
after hours God he's got so many yeah
he's one of the greats one of the greats
so I had a weird uh a weird I know we
got to start wrapping this up maybe but
I got a I love Color of Money he's got a
weird I had a weird talk with my agents
we had like a big Zoom meeting yeah and
I'm always that's always terrifying to
me we're like why we have this guy from
production we have this guy from the
movie side this guy from the book side
and you're Nick new seora all these
people and you're like oh I wonder what
this is about I thought it was going to
be some like tour stuff and they're like
I don't know how much I'm supposed to
divulge but they're like hey you're
you're you're doing great right now
you're selling tickets you're on Netflix
da D what's the next thing what what do
you want and I know we're working on a
movie but like I want to just be like
I've made it this is all I wanted was to
do theaters sell tickets write new
material put Clips up get a get a little
Instagram Buzz whatever like I'm good
but they made a good point they're like
but look at these old Comics you don't
you can't do the road when you're 59 I
mean you can but not like this you're
out every weekend you're hustling yeah
so they're like when you that's what
you're talking about trying to say like
yeah I know people are like you guys
aren't in shape but like you know we're
better than we could be for for having a
drinking podcast like so many Comics
died just from being out of shape not
just drugs Patrice and like John Panet
Louis Anderson so like yeah they're like
when you are that age you're going to
want to have this project that you can
just work on and like have a voiceover
or direct or create I'm like you had a
great voice for voiceover I would love
to do voice over but yeah also it just
seems easy it's easy you know I did like
a little bit on 10-year-old Tom I did
like five episodes but just like bit
parts and they were fun as hell it was
easy and he riffs like that's the thing
is like I hope that we just get more
opportunities creatively but I feel the
same way as you I I when I did that uh
Letterman thing he was like what's next
I was like what do you mean what's this
is I made it David Letterman
exactly so um and even this we get to
hang out and talk and it's a big
podcast you know I know I mean it's this
is great and I'm with you for me what I
want is more free time to write jokes
that's how I feel I just am like I want
to do less like cut out the unnecessary
yeah I want to work on my ACT I I
want more time because we are on the
road so hard and that means you
neglect stuff at home so when you're
home stuff piles up and that's the time
you need to recharge but they're like
you weren't here two days you got to do
this this and this yeah and uh I never
really rested in my career I never
really like I the same way we would land
and go straight to the comedy seller cuz
we like it yeah but but then they're
like what about this TV show and you're
like how am I going to fit writing a
show in like we were working on this
movie we have a a producer guy we have
writer guy we have us I think the
movie's going to be good man I think so
too I don't want to give too much away
cuz it's going to be a long process but
like I think it's in a good place script
is already amazing yeah and we haven't
even punched it up yet and it's already
funny so it we got to make edits and
stuff but like damn I'm I'm pumped I
think like you and me and a buddy comedy
is like it's going to be easy
and fun yeah and we know all the comics
but sure well we're taking it one we're
chipping away as they say and we got the
whiskey the problem is you know we had
that whiskey interview to today that was
oh yeah that was stressful yeah yeah
this guy really what you call him a
slasher he called him an old slasher he
was like a Texas you know kicking
hard ass guy he was like I never heard
of you boy I'm like I don't know I've
never heard of you either yeah you seem
successful is I mean you're doing great
we're doing great let's it is when a guy
takes a meeting with you goes I've never
heard of you and you're like you didn't
Google us before the meeting good point
you know yeah you ever heard of Netflix
huh tonight's show he perked up when
when when we were like well we've done
these shows stuff and he was like oh but
yeah he uh I feel like he would thrown
around whiskey industry terms just to
make us look stupid yeah we're not it
worked yeah we look stupid yeah he's
like where are you out of we like I
think
Indiana yeah I had an agent on the call
and he was just like well that was rough
and we're like yeah yeah that wasn't
good and it was 11 I was wearing boxers
under the under the screen it was I just
woke up so yeah it was it was a it was
very professional guy and a button down
and then a couple Comedians and a couple
guys with like dim lights Zoom yeah we
sucked but whatever I mean we still
might yeah he took the meeting and
Bodega cat I bet he Googled us at this
point so that helps just watches our
not for me that I bet that's the
type of guy where he's like not for me
probably yeah he feels more like a like
a Ron White Guy or maybe Nate barazi
yeah I could see that yeah but you live
you learn and we we'll figure it out
somebody's going to jump on on this
thing Bodega C man we need New York
distribution for the love of God please
clubs are willing to have us they've
already agreed to it and bars we got
lot so yeah that was the tough thing but
I see their point they're like you're
going to wish you had jumped on the iron
when it was hot in 20 years I think we
are though I think that that them being
on it means you will and and and
uh and it's true this touring right now
is
not sustainable for life of course but
my thing is and you've had this too I've
pitched I don't know 17 shows at this
point and again pitching with no juice
just going hey I got an idea will you
take a meeting and they go sure even
though they're just filling out a quota
you know for they're doing work by
taking a meeting with me they're not
actually going to make anything yeah can
you do a 4:30 p.m. on a on a Friday
you're like it feels important to you in
Santa Monica where you'll take two hours
to get there then four hours to get home
do you remember that do you remember
like remember going to pitch in
person all the time you lose your whole
day on two pitches but then I've tried
that never gotten anything then I've had
8,000 auditions never gotten one not one
so it just it gets a little frustrating
when they're like what about this movie
and like I'd love to be in that movie
but I'm not going to get the audition so
I know or also it's like I feel like the
we're going to get is when people
are like I like you you should be in my
thing that's it as oppos to showing up
blind and they're like oh we went with
uh with Johnny Depp instead you had me
competing against Johnny Depp exactly
exactly it was for guy who crazy
woman too of course he's going to get it
right I wouldn't get a role for a Mark
Norman type I could go in for that and
they' be like we're going to go with shy
laof it's so true yeah Louis black had
that story about he he lost out in the
part of Ls black oh really that's right
that's right but that's what it is I
mean like we're going against these like
people who they approach acting
the way we approach comedy it's going to
be a tough yeah process but uh yeah man
you are striking while the while the
Iron's hot you you're Restless I think
it's we will set up the next chapter
sure but it's like that Hedberg joke
where they're like you're funny you're
going to Comedy can you farm you know
like how what other things can you do
like I did this that was the whole point
but yeah but you when you were pitching
stuff you didn't have the juicy have now
you got people who are going to want to
make stuff with you now and uh the the
thing is
now do you ever think you'd be at a
point where like if someone was like I
want to cast Mark Norman as like the
wacky neighbor on this sitcom and you'd
be like I don't think I have time yeah
that's CRA now if you want if you're
going to make a show it's your show
that's true and that's a good place to
be in where you're like I'm good over
here I I feel comfortable I'm I'm I'm uh
you know I'm cool with if this is it
cool I don't I hope it's not I'd like to
keep going but I think uh this level is
great it's a good level we're working
we're uh you know if we make stuff it's
going to be this stuff if we any we love
standup so much that if we're going to
take a break from standup it better be
incredible of course and that's
a good place to be in that is a good
place to be in but I don't even know
what that thing is yet and they keep
going what's the thing you want to work
on I'm like I don't even know so like
what are you passionate about I'm like
stand up they're like but what's the
project I'm like I'll maybe I'll think
of it but I haven't I mean like this is
a new thing but like maybe it'll be like
a weird ass game show that you
made up maybe it'll be a thing you host
maybe it'll be a sitcom maybe it'll be
yeah you know a talk show there there's
so many maybe not a talk show because we
already do this so you you might be just
like you know that might be boring to
you I mean also what's what is a talk
show anymore I know a podcast is a talk
show now and a podcast is way better you
can get in there you can get real
whereas you know a Fallon you got eight
minutes you got to tell a silly story
that's been preapproved he laughs and
then the lights go on I will say though
I do kind of like the interview with the
crowd I like I like the idea that you
have to make it makes you on your
that's true that there's a crowd that
you have to get it's also like I don't
know it's almost like a sport you have
to like make it like let me make
sure let me choose this angle let me
leave let me try to like let me cut off
this party saying and try to slip in a
joke there's something cool about that
too oh yeah that's a skill in itself and
that is pretty awesome like those Bill
Burr panel moments were some of the
great Lou and Lou too there montages
Norm oh my God Norm made it like an art
but yeah there's montages of Bill Burr
just back to back to back on the couch
killing with basically with like bits
he's working on I followed one of them
on on Conan once and I remember it was a
Caitlyn Jenner bit that I was like wow
that's such a good take he was uh it was
like a pretty it was like Progressive
but also not Progressive at the same
time and I was like wow what a amazing
way to go both way it was like almost
like he was saying like good for her but
also like give me a minute yes and I was
like that's a very fair response he's
like if a guy had a beard for 20 years
and walked in without the beard you'd be
like what the hell man you changed yeah
it was great analogy it was a great
segment to follow cuz the crowd was in
stitches and you're like I I'm getting
to follow Bill Burr yeah how cool is
that and Bill bur just crushing yeah and
the height of his his uh
panel moment he he had a couple years of
panel which was like epic every time and
Conan uh I don't think Conan gets enough
credit for being like not just one of
the funniest people but like maybe the
best straight man maybe he could really
bring it out of you and he would poke a
little to make you prove your point and
that made it even better like he'd go I
don't know about that bill bill was like
what are you nuts and then now
he's worked up so it's kind of brilliant
the way he got it he knew how to play
contrarian in the right way he knew how
to
he almost became like the proper guy he
almost became like the The Authority the
voice of reason where he'd be like Bill
but that can't be like the guy he almost
made it like uh an office situation yeah
right where the guy's like you shouldn't
but that's not something you should and
then he kept but that keeps getting the
guy to go and you're like this is
what if he had never said to Norm do
something with that you freak and Norm's
like b o r e d you know like we wouldn't
have that great line with without Conan
feeding him like Hey think of something
now but he said it in the way so it made
it natural like he made him look like a
superhero feeding him that way exactly
that's the greatness of Conan just
knowing how it's like being a point
guard where you're just like I'm getting
you like the way Magic Johnson would
like get you to your spot he's like I'm
throwing the ball here get to your he
would do that with jokes he's pipping
yeah yeah he he just guard no it was a
small forward but but he's it was an
important part he's
assisting he rolling but you know animal
house but but you know it's like it's a
hard thing to do Carson was great at it
yes yes totally to make someone look
that good you really need to be a
sophisticated comedy mind oh yeah
whereas David Letterman who's also good
in his own way he was all he had the
ball he was his own you know three-point
shooter or whatever Steph Curry but he
that's why Comics would come on and kind
of bow to him yeah he was the number one
he was like the alpha but with Conan
he's he's a feeder and I almost like the
feeder better it's different yeah
um he really yeah he really made you
shine it was it was a tough thing to do
it's also tough for it's
really it's an amazing thing for a
comedian to completely just rid
themselves of their ego yeah and let you
shine yeah but it's for the good of the
show of course but Comics don't want to
that's true to not be the funniest one
totally totally you have to pull back
sometimes and let someone go yeah make
the segment go but it also has to be a
believable natural cuz Fallon who's
great and funny but he just laughs and
laughs so that's kind of his way of
being like keep going keep I'm
encouraging you but Conan did it in such
a smooth way that it looked like it
looked real right you know I
miss that I miss those segments he still
has his podcast and there you see
glimpses of it every now and then but
it's not the same without an audience
audiences really are they pull it out of
you a little more that's why sports are
in front of an audience you get the you
know home team rahah that gets you going
I how many we've all seen hooers you
know slow clap here we go the guy's on
his feet come on Williams get out there
Hackman dude Hackman by the way rip uh
he B Young
oh jeez Who the hell's Bert young are
you kidding me I know ber you're going
to feel bad
when Bert Reynolds Rocky back to
school I didn't know he died yeah I
thought he died years ago to be honest
so did I but uh I think that's Wallace
Shawn in the bottom or is that him
that's him but he turned into Wallace
sha no that's not what you want to hear
no I thought you were Wallace sha he's a
fatter Wallace Sha but he's the ultimate
schlubby character actor he's so good I
I love to line him back to school when
he go when Dangerfield goes uh he goes
Lou he goes girls this is Lou Lou these
are
girls yes yes look at that
wow that guy had never paid for a drink
at a bar I guarantee you he walked in
they go holy it's the guy from
Rocky old man bakala and Sopranos
remember he does that one last hit he's
got
the oh yeah wow what a career
Legend there him with Nicholson on the
right is it is that uh Chinatown I
assume wow damn I forgot he's in
Chinatown what a career Bert young now
how many podcasts out there are talking
about Bert young that's all I'm saying
we got R we love movies and uh you know
yeah he deserves his due full
stop brute young clap clap was one of
the finest clap clap actors that we've
ever
had
yes you guys you guys are the best
thanks for listening but see us on the
road Mark where you going to be I'm all
over the place new tour dates announced
Mark nman du comedy.com you don't say
tour rolls on we're cooking we're going
to Tampa we're going to Cleveland we're
going all of Denver we got a second show
added all kinds of stuff The Beacon
Theater in January come on out tickets
are moving uh see you in New Orleans for
Thanksgiving or is that over
no that's okay great Santa Rosa whever
the hell that is that'll be fun and yeah
all kinds of stuff back in New England
going to Miami going off Jacksonville
you name it Bert Cher cruise this
weekend I might die who knows we'll see
you s to bail on that one oh everybody
pulled everybody pulled out of that it
was I'm out too much you Whitney Tim
Whitney ba yeah Whitney got Chris De
bailed I mean it's me and sea Patton in
a life booat just
swimming I'm I'm dying it's like the
Titanic I should have I should have
gotten out Brisbane Melbourne Adel
Sydney I'm all over Australia baby hope
to see you out there got Vegas at the
wind December 2nd Tampa December 8th
Fort Meers December 9th and I'm going to
hit some comedy clubs again I'm back in
the clubs for a minute to gear up for
the special uh in Boston in March so we
got Buffalo Springfield Madison Philly
Dan Beach Omaha Dallas Oklahoma City
Irvine Lake City and then we got the
special baby two of them already
sold out and probably more by now so see
your asses on the road let's go
we love you get some Bodega cat get some
Bodega cat we're working on this guys
this is not our business and we a lot of
it's been put on us and we're busy
so we're trying we're
trying folks we're hustling we're doing
what we got to do and uh yeah thanks for
listening we got shirts we got sweaters
we got glasses get on it we'll see you
in hell love you guys
[Music]
sued
Sam I'm out to lunch here in New Orleans
this woman doesn't look
remember and I get down in
[Music]
the
we
be
true